since a lot of Avatar the way of water
was filmed in a giant tank of water the
film's actors didn't have quick easy
access to a bathroom so what did they do
when Nature inevitably called here's the
embarrassing admission a few of the
actors made considering it took 13 years
to get Avatar the way of water in
theaters following the massive success
of Avatar it's safe to say James Cameron
and his crew face their fair share of
challenges for starters Cameron once
again had to develop all-new performance
capture technology to adequately get
actors performance in water instead of
merely hanging actors from wires to
assimilate weightlessness Cameron had
actors swim in a giant tank so that they
actually had resistance from the water
to inform their performances
and we capture a hundred percent of
their performance in the digital world
it was an undertaking unlike any other
and the results speak for themselves on
the big screen the characters really
look like they're swimming in a reef to
the point where it's hard not to believe
you're watching a documentary of aliens
floating about in the ocean however the
water tank the actors swam in presented
more challenges than how to capture
performances digitally According to some
of the actors some people had a hard
time refraining from urinating in the
tank turning the Pinnacle of CGI
creation into a glorified public pool
Jack champion who plays spider and
Bailey bass who plays Soraya did an
interview with pop buzz where they
played Jenga and answered questions
related to Avatar the way of water when
asked to recall the funniest memory from
the set Champion responded
and everyone knows you're a liar if you
say you haven't peed in the tank because
it's long hours everyone
Champion went on to recall a
conversation he had with Britain Dalton
who plays lawak in the film where he
admitted to urinating in the tank 100
times Dalton meanwhile said he never
went in it at this point Champion was
worried he would get in trouble but
plenty of other people admitted to using
the tank as a bathroom so he was in the
clear still Dalton remained adamant that
he never went in the tank which caused
Champion to be pretty skeptical to be
fair it would be pretty inconvenient if
every time someone needed to use the
restroom they had to be pulled out of
the tank they'd then have to take off
their wetsuit go to the bathroom and
then come back which could get
cumbersome if you have a lot of people
needing to go to the bathroom all at
once hopefully people took it easy on
drinking coffee before getting into the
water perhaps it's for this reason other
cast members have admitted to urinating
in the tank while filming in an
interview with variety Sam Worthington
said that he was prone to relieving
himself while submerged underwater he
went on the record saying there is a lot
of stuff going on in that water that you
Don don't really discuss you're 30 foot
down and you need to go you go you hope
that the water doesn't turn pink with at
least several actors going to the
bathroom while in the tank it's amazing
the water didn't turn yellow at some
point with a run time of 192 minutes you
may find yourself needing to use the
restroom part way through Avatar the way
of water still plenty of people have
held it in propelling the Blockbuster
sequel to become the number one film at
the box office during its opening
weekend
foreign
[Music]